that is sister mary catherine one of the
rally nuns throwing out the first pitch
tonight here he is luis garcia
we saw him from one plus in game two
what do you expect tonight i expect a
little different music in his uh rhythm
emotion schwarber held on at first by
yuli the o1 and that's a ground ball hit
sharply diving stopped by altuve from
his knees throws the first of the hop
and time to get hernandez outstanding
play by altuve to the left of second in
the shift and had to throw from the knee
to get the out boy what a momentum
changer jose altuve
all out effort to his right and that
ball was buying by the time he snagged
it
nathan ibaldi who is working on two days
rest after the 24 pitches took the loss
tuesday game four at fenway yardon
having a fantastic alcs eight for 19.
421 average a home run a double he's
driven in five
in the air to right center field back
at the truck it is
off the wall in the score is bregman and
the astros strike first in game six
it looked like kiki hernandez got there
and was unable to secure it
it was going to be a basket catch for
[ __ ] he ran a mile that ball was in the
air forever
on the warning track just before the
wall in and out of the glove
there's the pitch and a swing of the
drive toward the gap in left center
field over goes verdugo hard he slides
and he made the catch stumbling over he
had a severe outfield shift there and he
was almost a dead center when he caught
it so this time they do not score with
two down thanks to a good running catch
by verdugo went into a slide with a
backhand play gotta give alvarez a
chance with a man on jordan continues to
stay hot 10 postseason games now
including this one
a 375 average and nine rbis
hit the other way
red hot is alvarez
digging for third bregman second and
third
nobody else
and see i said the hard part is
repeating it
you watch where the sign and the
location is going to be
but because he's so good out over the
plate there's nothing he fears and he
was trying to get that ball up and in
and he threw it up and away and he's got
such a simple swing foot down and he's
not doing much he's letting the power of
the pitcher do the work for him
he would not have been able to get to
the ball up and in
down in the series facing elimination
second and third trailing in the ball
game
struck him out one down as correa chased
it
one and two the pitch swing and a miss
he struck him out on a curveball in the
dirt poleecki picks it out throws the
first two downs of all the throws
swinging a miss he struck him out nato
valde strikes out the side after
the astros had him at second and third
and then the base is loaded unbelievable
stuff from nate of aldi tonight it's
luis garcia who has not allowed a hit
through four and a third
that goes flying into the net out of the
hands of arroyo
it was halfway into the netting and the
nationals fan reached over the dugout
and pulled it through for his own
souvenir
strikeout number five
two out
the one-two to hunter renfro swinging a
mess struck him out on a cutter down and
away
luis garcia with six strikeouts
and he has set down the last 11 in a row
hasn't allowed a hit
after ivaldi
exits ground ball schwarber throws
wide
and they get the out
but no double play
[Applause]
out at second safe at first is brantley
two out
and schwarber still relatively new to
first base and that has shown itself
here a couple times over the last two
games
josh sets and fires
ground ball hit right to the shortstop
xander has it flips to royo for the
fourth and second that retires the side
pitch
a strikeout starts the ending number
seven for garcia
change up just
filthy disappearing on the
outside part of the plate you can see
him kind of wave at it and hope to just
follow it off
3-2
left center field
back at the wall it's off the wall
digging for second and now heading for
third [ __ ] hernandez and the tying run
90 feet away
with two out
an absolute
missile high off the wall
and that's going to be the last pitch
that garcia throws
it was a fastball center cut and kiki
crushed it i thought he had one it
looked like it would carry out oh they
got a break
dabber skies one on the infield
correa says he's got it
ends the top of the
sixth eurodon alvarez leads it off he's
two for two with a pair of doubles
that's down the right field another hit
into the corner alvarez digs for two
he's thinking he's going
lead off
triple
with his first triple of the night and
his third extra base hit right fielder
renfro was playing him in right center
field
and as soon as it got over the first
baseman's head
it was off to the races a triple for the
big man
[Applause]
first and third nobody out and kyle
tucker deals with houck tucker on three
and one
hits it hard scooped up by schwarber run
comes to the plate safe it's two nothing
it's a double play at first as the
runner correa was tagged
schwarber stepped on the bag he got two
the astros get the run
and double their lead and the bases are
empty with two down
three and two
he goes here's the pitch swing and a
miss throw to second
machete
he did it
double play
maldonado
a cannon to second base
and that is the
threat the juice box is going nuts the
red sox roll the dice send the runner
and maldonado says
not on my watch
right-hander is set
3-2
and that's popped up on the infield who
wants it calling for it correa to the
right of second waiting for it on the
infield dirt makes the one-handed grab
stanek with the flex as he comes off the
mound
and that's alvarez at second correa at
first astros looking to add to their
two-nothing lead with two outs 2-1
and tucker hits it pretty well and
pretty deep to left going back schwarber
on the warning track looking up and that
ball's gone
into the first floor of the landry's
crawford boxes kyle tucker with a three
run homer and the astros lead is five to
nothing
by the slimmest of margins
tucker provides the astros
with some breathing room
and wouldn't you know it it comes with
two outs tucker the dagger
five-nothing houston lead into the ninth
inning of game six ryan presley takes
over
0-2
fly ball ended left center
mccormick coming to get it
one out
the one-two to deavers swing and a mess
struck him out on a curve ball
the red sox
are down to the final out of their
season
bogart's the 0-1 and this is lifted in
the left field it backs up brantley he
makes the catch and the houston astros
are headed to the world series your
20-21 american league champions the
houston astros a mob scene to the left
of the pitcher's mound as the astros win
shutting out the red sox five to nothing
and take the american league
championship series four games to two
boy what a team effort for the astros
shutting down this
daunted red sox lineup
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes